c'est assez surprenant quand on est
ministre on a un cabinet et dont une
administration on doit être responsable
d'ailleurs le porte-parole du
gouvernement l'a dit je crois à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres et dans
ces auditions là on a vu plutôt moi je
souhaite d'abord saluer le travail du
Sénat qui en capacité parce qu'on
transparte César de monnaie ce type de
commission d'enquête mais aussi revenir
sur les deux préfets qui ont été
auditionnés celui qui était à l'époque
directeur du cpdr et celui qui était
directeur de cabinet le comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délanquant c'est de la radicalisation et
le directeur de cabinet de marine Chapa
les deux je crois ont été assez honnête
d'ailleurs on dit très clairement les
choses à la fois ce qu'ils avaient fait
et puis aussi ils ont aussi dit
notamment le préfet cravet il a aussi
dit que l'on lui avait une forme de
pression poétique une forme de commande
poétique qui ne répondait pas au canon
j'ai envie de dire habituel de travail
de sérieux donc ça moi je trouve ça bien
après Marlène Schiappa je crois qu'elle
ne répondait pas en fait aux questions
de la commission d'enquête mais plutôt
elle s'interrogeait sur d'autres
éléments puisque vous vous savez qu'il y
a des enquêtes qui sont ouvertes il y a
le parquet nation financier je crois
qu'elle le répondait surtout pas avant
ce parquet à financier puisque
finalement elle était ministre elle
était après au courant de rien un après
décider de rien et elle avait le choix
entre assumer sa responsabilité ou
passer pour quelqu'un qui était assez
légère dans la gestion d'un ministère et
donc ça nous inquiète sur cette gestion
justement
de cette audition au Sénat je ne sais
pas est-ce que c'est normal qu'une
ministre ne sache pas ce qui se passe
dans son propre cabinet mais non mais je
crois que tous les élus quand vous êtes
mère président moi-même j'ai été
collaborateur de cabinet vous aurez fait
à votre Ministre et en tout cas de fait
le ministre ou le maire doit assumer la
responsabilité de son administration de
son cabinet et par ailleurs le directeur
de cabinet a indiqué que sur une
association SOS Racisme la ministre
avait dit non tout se lèverait il est
indiqué qu'il y a eu des échanges entre
monsieur Sifa et notamment et Madame
Chapa donc tout ça existe
c'est totalement défaussée et pas
défausser c'est pour être pour être poli
je crois qu'on a assisté
je crois que ça a été en direct le crash
d'une ministre très honnêtement puisque
maintenant tout le monde comprendra que
soit n'assume pas ses responsabilités
soit finalement n'était pas ministre la
question c'est que durablement rester à
son poste selon vous
il y a une seule responsabilité celle du
prix en république qui nomme une
première ministre et donc de fait son
gouvernement si le prix en république
estime qu'elle doit rester c'est son
souci à lui avec tout ce qu'elle cela
suppose s'il souhaite s'en séparer c'est
son souci à lui voilà et je pense que
notre rôle nous en tant que Sénat c'est
d'avoir mené cette commission d'enquête
il faut salu également le travail de
journaliste qui ont mis en exerg
notamment tout cela donc nous faisons de
commission d'enquête et comme vous le
disiez le d'ici le 13 juillet le
président claudana remettra avec le
rapporteur Husson son rapport et puis le
Sénat ensuite a attiré des conséquences
de tout cela je rappelle que les
rapports du Sénat c'est pas de savoir on
n'est pas la justice mais c'est de voir
ce qui s'est réellement passé s'appelle
le contrôle c'est dans la conscience et
aussi faire des préconisations pour
éviter d'autres situations de cette
nature là quand on lance un fond il y a
aussi des règles à manifestants à mettre
en place qui n'était pas le cas à ce
moment-là mais politiquement est-ce que
vous diriez que Marine Chapa est
affaibli aujourd'hui avec cette affaire
moi je trouve que je vais pas aller sur
la forme et sur le fond il a dit très
clairement qu'il avait été approché par
Mans Chapa et son cabinet pour rentrer
dans la dans l'appel à projet voilà les
choses sont claires il a expliqué en
quoi il pouvait faire il a expliqué que
très vite on lui a dit qu'il y aurait
pas de suite vraiment donc tout ça s'est
arrêté la question encore une fois
revient surtout à pourquoi se font là
alors vous avez aussi faut pas l'oublier
et je le dis vous avez dans en France
des milliers d'associations on peut pas
dire plus qui bossent au quotidien sur
des des choses aussi similaires et que
ces associations là et pas que lui
pourquoi se font là parce que le bruit
est pas aidé celle qui aujourd'hui au
quotidien travaille des gens bénévoles
qui font ça au quotidien en plus de leur
travail etc et ben on donne notre
sentiment que finalement il y a du
tripatouage alors que des millions de
Français sont dans une association et le
travail très bien et qui d'ailleurs
association qui demande des crédits qui
n'ont pas et quand ils voient quand ces
personnes à voient ce ce scandale là
effectivement on peut être juste écœuré
justement ça va jeter le discrédit sur
le travail de des associations qui dans
l'ombre contre la radicalisation
il y a globalement mais moi justement
c'est pour ça je souhaite le rendre
hommage grâce à votre antenne je pense
qu'il faut que les Français entendent
bien que les associations bossent
aujourd'hui sur le terrain et non pas
attendu le fond Marianne et non pas
attendu madame Schiappa et je voudrais
appeler encore une fois d'autant plus
choquant que c'est après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty qui est qui vivait dans mon
département qui es-tu dans mon
département que cela a été lancé donc
comment à partir d'un drame qui aurait
dû ressouder la nation on termine avec
ce ce j'ai en dire je ne sais pas c'est
des pieds nickel ou des barbouzes on n'a
pas bougerie mais c'est scandaleux donc
moi je souhaite endommage encore une
fois il faut saluer un mois il se
rappelle la mémoire de sympathise qui
est arrivé dans quel cadre et c'est je
salue le fait que nous ayons une
commission d'enquête au Sénat qui va
justement comprendre la mécanique folle
des 10 ou 15 jours qui a conduit à
justement à cette descente aux enfers
jusqu'à l'assassinat odieux de Samuel
Paty donc c'est une bonne chose
elle a été validée par le Bureau du
Sénat et par ailleurs je le dis à des
millions de Français dans les
associations qui au quotidien boss et
qui ne sont pas de nature de celle que
vient de voir
[Musique]